hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast Anna just checking in on you oh
I almost passed out doing that uh-huh
I'm just checking in on just seeing all
your week's going how's it going man
you're almost there you're almost there
you're almost to the weekend it's gonna
be your world again you're gonna get to
do sigh decide when you wake up do
sidenote decide that's the greatest
[ __ ] thing about Saturday morning you
decide all right and I don't care if
you've got kids I don't care if you've
got a wife you got a husband and they're
staying are you guys yeah and you think
I need you to shut the [ __ ] up you're
not the boss of me
it's sad I'm staying in this [ __ ] bed
oh yeah the kids crying sweetheart I am
cried what are they crying they didn't
want the [ __ ] they're crying about huh
they downstairs you know what are they
doing right now
what are they crying about what toy does
somebody want that somebody else say
yeah that's not a life-or-death
situation I am going to lay in this
[ __ ] bed and I want to get up why not
that's what Saturday is all about Santa
that feeling you have on Saturday
morning when you can basically do
whatever the [ __ ] it is you want
provided the woman in your life is
afraid of you choking you can do
whatever it is the [ __ ] you want to do
all right that feeling right there
that's the feeling that you should be
working towards okay that misery that
Monday through Friday wake and I gotta
wake light I gotta wake up cuz I have
because I [ __ ] I get an agreement
with these people down the street that I
have to be there and they have to be
able to see my face at this particular
[ __ ] time and I got a trudge in here
and do this [ __ ] job however
once you get to feel what it's like to
be living your dream at Granny's you got
to be thinking what bill I can't [ __ ]
lay in a bed a whole [ __ ] you know
Monday through Sunday how would I eat
how would I eat that right there is what
handouts are for
that's what 7-elevens are for you want
to sleep in every day this is what you
do you sit outside of 7-eleven you make
a little sign alright you don't write it
on a nice piece of notebook paper you
got to write it on like a piece of trash
you so people know that you struggling
right now [ __ ] with you somehow you
got you got to become self-employed you
got to work for yourself if you want
that Saturday morning grant you're gonna
still be working you know only you can
work Monday through Friday when you're
self-employed you're Mork Monday through
Sunday but you'll get up when you want
to get up alright and you at least have
that feeling of a little bit of control
and freedom then he can take it too far
like the ultimate Saturday I'll get up
when the ever the [ __ ] I want to is that
fatty cakes there in North Korea okay
and you can tell by his build that guy
sleeps till at least eleven everyday you
know I bet he has like kid pajamas does
he look like he would you know giant
Speed Racer bed or some [ __ ] something
about him seems very childish you know I
don't know you know what it is I bet he
just because he was the the dictators
son nobody ever picked on him but he
looked in the mirror and he was like the
only reason why they're not picking on
me right now is because if they did my
dad would feed them naked to wild dogs
that's the only thing stopping him look
how fat I am look at me just standing
there looking at his hair hairy Perlas
[ __ ] torso right
I bet he's getting any right some man
whole [ __ ] level any there's some
whole enemies trying to fill
anyways I don't what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about how about those Cleveland
goddamn Indians 21 victories in a row
you never yeah that's [ __ ] amazing
that is really amazing and how great
would it be to see them end there what
was it 1948 they ended it this year I
don't know about my Red Sox I don't know
I'm gonna keep saying that hoping I
kicked them into coming together I kind
of [ __ ] fell out of love with this
team I've said it before when they
[ __ ] yelled at Eckersley outside come
on
there was no discipline about that's a
Hall of Famer you know what you're doing
a Hall of Famer walks in a room you shut
the [ __ ] up that's what you do and if he
criticizes you you say okay fair enough
I'll try a little better there sport
maybe ask for his audit now now you
don't ask for his autograph you want to
be a professional you want if you want
to act like you're you're in the same
business you never asked for an
autograph within the same industry okay
don't ever forget that I've seen people
do it it's an ugly ugly [ __ ] scene I
know a guy that [ __ ] played golf and
a celebrity [ __ ] tournament right why
can't I ever type in my password and
talk at the same [ __ ] time it's
unbelievable he played in a celebrity
golf tournament and one of the guys in
his foursome was actually a fan of his
and they're [ __ ] hanging out there
Palin around everything's going great
and then when they were done at the end
of the round he asked for a picture and
the guy's face just dropped and that was
it it was over he went from hanging out
with that guy to being back in the crowd
throwing his panties at him what is my
point my point is I like sleeping in on
[Music]
all right let's see what I don't have
anything to talk about today cuz I'm
just stuck in a [ __ ] writers room we
just were doing the table read this
morning for episode 307 well I can't be
screaming my daughter's still sleeping
my mother my wife's probably gonna
[ __ ] kill me right now on say is
there a reason why ever since Bill
Clinton they just won't let somebody be
President
I really think you know what it is I
think it's because if I think it's cuz
of social media and 24 hours news
works and all of that type of [ __ ] this
is like CNN CNN who refuses to cover any
anything about Hillary and the
Democratic Party ignoring the votes
during the primary in boxing out Bernie
Sanders who actually got more votes and
then Hillary actually has the [ __ ]
balls to be like we should do away with
the Electoral College oh because the
[ __ ] over that you ran on Bernie Sanders
then was done to you I've never seen
such an entitled [ __ ] person
everybody talks about how entitled Trump
is and I'm not saying he isn't jesus
[ __ ] christ she really thought that
that job was hers it's [ __ ]
unbelievable anyways it's
un-fuckin'-believable
all right it says Sean Spicer basically
admitted that he was willing to live for
Trump now
what is shocking about that do you think
there was nobody in Obama's cabinet that
was willing to lie for him or bushes or
Clinton's or first bush or Reagan or
Carter that's what happens think about
in your life there's people you're
willing to lie for you know your buddies
[ __ ] hammered behind the wheel the
cop comes up you sit down sir he's
always fine he's only had a couple you
know you do that it's a friend jesus
[ __ ] christ and everybody [ __ ]
sitting here acting like the president
runs the country is [ __ ] hilarious
like his decisions aren't decided by all
the money that you [ __ ] need to get
in the [ __ ] office right I don't know
they keep saying did Trump use most of
his own money I doubt it I don't [ __ ]
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about I'm just so [ __ ] sick of people
you know acting like this guy is way
worse than the other guy cuz of two or
three issues other than that as far as
the environment as far as the food
supply as far as the heroin epidemic
it's the exact same thing don't [ __ ]
say [ __ ] about it right is that what it
is I don't
all right after Chicago teenager is
found dead in a walk-in Hotel freezer
mystery lingers this is why I don't want
you think North Korea's latest nuclear
test was so powerful it reshaped the
mountain above it okay yeah well yeah
what's nuclear power it's powerful
Russia fires cruise missile at is
stronghold is that the cool way to say
Isis now is is stronghold in East Syria
Russia is about to kick off a war game
that is freaking out NATO here's what we
know this is why I don't read the new I
wouldn't know wouldn't know any of this
it's a game they're having a game they
can't play a game in their own country
coordinated attack in southern Iraq
kills at least 50 okay no good news yet
alright let's go to the United States
let's see what good news is here eight
dead after South Florida nursing homes
air conditioning fails following
hurricane
great next one as the White House calls
for her firing ESPN's Jamel Hill
addressed the elephant in the room what
the [ __ ] is this how the [ __ ] did we go
from the White House to a reporter on
ESPN know this now this I'll tell you
this here I got a read this one I got a
read all right here we go here we go
what do we say House hours after a White
House spokesperson called for ESPN to
fire her because she called President
Trump a white supremacist on Twitter
Jamil hill or Jamel Motul Hill tweeted
about the topic Wednesday night saying
she was going to address the elephant in
the room after becoming the latest
flashpoint in a cultural skirmish that
has involved the sports network once
again hash tagging your tweets hash tag
facts Hill wrote my comments on Twitter
expressed my personal belief my regard
my regret is that my comments at
in the public way I made them painted
ESPN in an unfair light my respect for
the company of my colleagues remains
unconditional yeah how the [ __ ] do you
have that job and no you can't tweet
some [ __ ] like that you're gonna get
fired because at the end of the day all
ESPN gives a [ __ ] about his ratings in
money that's what they care about
alright so when asked Wednesday
afternoon by the post david nakamura
nakamura that's a good last name about
Hills original tweets Sara Huckabee
Sanders said she was unsure whether the
president was aware of the kerfuffle
they caused but at course he was aware
ok [ __ ] tweets every day's like a
seventh grade girl I think that's one of
the more outrageous comments that anyone
could make and certainly something that
I think is fireable offense by ESPN get
that [ __ ] out of here Oh give me a
[ __ ] break
I love out ESPN thinks that reflects on
them and all they need is a couple
people Yocto you're on nap you know
further detail about my president are
you gonna watch to see if the Yankees
beat the [ __ ] Indians tonight yes you
are what else are you gonna do read a
book it's a sports network this is some
of the dumbest people on the planet
myself included do you how many times
I've tried I've gotten so disgusted with
the NFL I tried to walk away then I just
had to admit that I was too weak to do
it I like how the NFL ratings are down
now and they're trying to blame that
stupid Colin Kaepernick thing that's
what it was oh that's what it wasn't
what you know what it was is they just
got greedy I think it's the NFL a
pleasure it goes in cycles too you know
what I mean it's like the NBA where they
had bird magic into [ __ ] Jordan and
then there was a little bit of a lull
there for a minute right and then like I
don't know I guess the Spurs weren't
[ __ ] exciting enough I don't know and
then you know eventually other guys came
along LeBron came along yeah the next
one right I think football goes to the
same thing but the problem is these
please these guys in the NFL they're
trying to go global and they're trying
to
P like please as many people as humanly
possible so they kind of abandoned their
original pinyin you know with the NBA is
right now the NBA is where you to was
when bono started wearing those big fly
glasses the big mosquito glasses and was
saying [ __ ] like this is the most
surreal night of my life man he started
playing a character you know in eight
years they went from carrying a [ __ ]
white flag and all whatever the [ __ ] it
is they were doing back then I was never
the big YouTube guy okay as I told you
before I didn't listen to the right
music in the eighties I was listening to
crocus and HELOCs I was listening to all
those [ __ ] pants you know I mean and
then I was watching sports and I was
flunking math and French class I mean
that's basically what you've been
listening to all these years if you ever
wondered I don't need to go to
ancestry.com to figure out my mystery I
am a [ __ ] dope I am a dope dope when
I walk into a room dopes shut up just to
listen to what stupid thing I'm going to
say anyways yeah they [ __ ] they they
did the pink thing let's have the
football players wear pink I love how
like for some reason the fact that a
football is a really male testosterone
aggressive thing that like for some
reason guys have to apologize for that
and they just can't effeminate
is that the word effeminate they can't
make it like like feminine enough all of
a sudden because all these feminists
[ __ ] moaning and complaining has all
these corporations all in a myth like oh
we don't want to be considered sexist
the next thing you know that we're in
pink for a month is if the NFL gives a
flying [ __ ] about anything other than
making money
cancer
is what we care about your brain turning
into scrambled eggs yeah we don't get
you killing yourself by the time you're
50 we don't give a [ __ ] about that oh is
that what you did here's 40 bucks for
everybody who ever played the [ __ ]
game they don't give a [ __ ]
according to reports they kept like 95
to 97 dollars every hundred dollars they
made off of that pink [ __ ] so give me a
[ __ ] break
they show people in the crowd that are
in the military they charge that branch
in the military they treat it like a
commercial as they tell you to support
the troops the [ __ ] out of here right so
now what so now these women's groups sit
there [ __ ] moaning and complaining so
now they got they got female referees
they got women calling the games they
got the guys wearing pink for an entire
[ __ ] month they got Lady Gaga singing
at the [ __ ] halftime at the Super
Bowl they took a total [ __ ] left turn
and when you do that like u2 is you're
gonna lose a lot of your original
fanbase that are like hey man I liked
them back when the boy I liked the first
album I saw him when there was only
8,000 people at the [ __ ] show that's
basically what they're going through and
they're gonna survive it and they're
gonna transition from you know the
frozen tundra and all of that [ __ ]
you know making it seem like it was
[ __ ] d-day all of that great [ __ ]
that I loved they are going to
transition out of all of that and I
think that there's gonna be a lot more
fuchsias in in Till's and all that type
of stuff coming into the NFL
as they try to I don't know I think as
they try to get ahead of this next
generation of people that come that's
coming up that goes out to comedy clubs
and literally just stares at the
comedian's like that's what I'm
experiencing now I was at the Comedy
Store last night granted something
[ __ ] up happened before I want a stage
I guess I should have realized that and
they yeah just just staring at me
staring at me so I don't know I don't
know what I have to do you know I'm
thinking it actually maybe I'll start
wearing pink on stage and then people
will think that I care
um anyways I I don't want to I don't
want to [ __ ] I don't want to call out
any [ __ ] specific [ __ ] people I
don't want to [ __ ] do that cuz you
know I sucked as a comedian eventually I
got better at it but I mean jesus
[ __ ] christ if you're gonna go down
that road you still have to pick
somebody that's of a [ __ ] certain
level of professionalism though you're
gonna have a [ __ ] national game that
means Jesus Christ and I'm not talking
about that poor bastard that froze like
a deer in a headlight that [ __ ] kid
on the side so I just felt bad for that
too you don't I mean but I'm just saying
you know if you're gonna call a [ __ ]
game good [ __ ] lord good lord this is
actually my dream my dream is somebody
that like is like a [ __ ] went to
broadcasting school and then you pair
him up with someone that played the game
I know they tried to do that all the
time but someone that actually can tell
a story that played the [ __ ] game
that's when it's the best like
Collinsworth John Madden Phil I love
Phil had people didn't like Phil saying
I love Phil Simms but I [ __ ] he won a
Super Bowl he's the first guy to say I'm
going to Disneyland I'm not gonna listen
to this guy all these guys who play
fantasy football trying to say the guy
doesn't know what he's talking about
yeah what would he know about well you
know he only played the game
professionally you [ __ ] [ __ ] um I
don't know wait a second what the [ __ ]
is going on here all right I don't know
what the hell I just did I had my
recorder on the floor I don't know when
the hell I just chopped it off but I had
the thing recording on the wrong speed I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened
anyways I don't [ __ ] I don't know what's
going I know what's going on at comedy
clubs I don't know what's going on and
in the NFL I don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing and this is just just part
of becoming old like why I gotta put
their street lights up so bright like
I'm just an old man don't [ __ ] listen
to me
anyways I don't understand how I had a
half hour to do this before nine o'clock
and it's almost nine o'clock and I only
have [ __ ] 20 minutes done probably
because I stepped on the recorder nicely
the [ __ ] worst I'm the worst
anyways so congratulations the NFL I
know you guys want to go global I hope
you [ __ ] do it
you know I'm sure you're jealous of the
UFC that started way after you guys and
they were able to do it you are sure you
know I don't know what the [ __ ] to tell
you I don't know what the [ __ ] to tell
you it's just like I don't I I I kind of
like college football might start
watching that then eventually they're
gonna get pressure to [ __ ] make this
game a male testosterone game for some
reason we need a bunch of estrogen in it
you know this is what I don't understand
about women okay every study says that
they're way smarter than men right they
can handle a stronger level of pain
they're more in touch with their
emotions they could do all of that [ __ ]
and you know for them far as my
experience goes I'd agree with it for
the most part I don't know about the
arrogant we're smarter than you it
depends on what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
right but I'll give you I'll give you
all of that but if that's all true
what if [ __ ] can't you start your own
sports league why don't you do that
what do you constantly have to [ __ ]
infiltrate some [ __ ] a bunch of guys
doing some [ __ ] that you know at the end
of the day you think it's [ __ ] stupid
it's a bunch of guys smashing into each
other scrambling their [ __ ] brains
trying to get a ball across the [ __ ]
line to score points you know you don't
give a [ __ ] about that why can't they
come up with their own goddamn [ __ ]
sports league and then from top to
bottom [ __ ] can be all women then you
turn that thing into a global
billion-dollar [ __ ] entity and then
women get all that [ __ ] money there's
your power you know [ __ ] join a guy's
league and then they give you a pink
flags to throw holding offense like why
would you do that
I don't know I don't [ __ ] know I
don't know I don't understand these
things all I can all I could do is we
equate it to my life is I can tell you
this when I work for somebody else let's
say I like the [ __ ] overs you can't you
can't keep you can't keep track of them
that's when you get stolen from the most
that's when your dream gets crushed the
most when you [ __ ] work for somebody
else if you work for yourself you have
more control granted you work way more
hours but that's the price you pay we're
taking callers all right let me read a
little bit of advertising here everybody
by the way [ __ ] Oh Billy no fun no
booze 28 days 28 days a week I don't
[ __ ] in booze 28 days a week I stare at
the ceiling trying to go to sleep oh I
love that whiskey it's my Tylenol PM
speaking of which this is gonna be the
biggest test for my air-quote sobriety
I'm not [ __ ] sober I'm just not
drinking okay all right this is the
biggest test saucy thoughthey Miya guys
saucy everyone at some point has wished
they could just have beer wine or liquor
delivered well someone finally decided
to do something about it oh my god I
love these people next please mention
all the talking points below dude I'll
[ __ ] sing these if you want to want me
to introducing thoughthey meow the
alcohol delivering app saucy Oreo
delivers your favorite wine and beer and
liquor right to your door on demand it's
uber for alcohol this is great this is
[ __ ] great
uber is great right I should say lyft
cuz they [ __ ] advertise on us right
oh I love those those those guys that
lift and the ladies right they [ __ ]
yeah they cut down on drinking and
driving right now they're gonna cut down
on [ __ ] ruining the ozone layer well
I guess someone still has to drive
liquor store drive it over to you
whatever all I know is you're not the
street dude you
turn your [ __ ] apartment into the
club you never leave they never shut you
off this is great okay now if you're in
Los Angeles San Francisco Chicago San
Diego a whale's vagina or Sacramento
your thathe order will arrive at your
door in 30 minutes or less ready to
drink all right guys now la San
Francisco Chicago San Diego Sacramento
you got a [ __ ] drink up you got to
get these people the money that they
need to expand all right for the right
this is like the original six except as
five cities first okay for the rest of
us thought they will deliver beer wine
and liquor to your door in two days or
less nationwide there are no minimums no
order minimums no delivery fees no
running to the store if you've got the
saasy app around you got a fully stocked
bar on your phone and for a limited time
dude you can start drinking top-shelf
booze now because you're not going out
playing a cover and raining that type of
[ __ ] okay you go out you [ __ ] rub one
out at home okay you just hey no more
hitting on chicks right I may be by that
[ __ ] robot doll that came out last
year for ten grand that you can bank
that eventually Joe Rogan was tweeting
that you can [ __ ] hackers can hack
into it and teach it to kill you three
scary days coming up anyways and for a
limited time you can get $15 off your
download well when you download the
saucy app and enter promo code birth
that's saucy meow app spelled sauc ey
honey and enter promo code BIR for $15
off gets the saucy app today and use
promo code burn alright draftkings
everybody week one is in the books but
it's it's not too late to get closer to
the game you love Carl crawl right up
the ass crack of the NFL with draftkings
one-week fantasy football this Sunday
draftkings is hosting a $100,000
degenerate gambler pick'em contest that
is totally free to enter pick'em is the
newest way to play one week fantasy
football drafting your team as FS
than ever draftkings has organized
players into eight tiers all you have to
do is select one player from each tier
choose between the public choose between
public contests with big cash prizes or
private contests we can compete against
a group of your friends draftkings also
has beginner and casual contests where
you'll play against people of a similar
skill level the best part is you get to
draft a new team each week without any
commitment so get draftkings.com now and
use promo code burr to play in
draftkings free contests with a $100,000
drop dollars in total prizes this Sunday
use my promo code Bertram to play for
free this Sunday that's promo code burr
at draft kings.com eligibility
restrictions apply see draft kings.com
for details oh look who's back
everybody's simply theth the average
property lost from chess one home
break-in is too [ __ ] grand two
thousand three hundred sixteen dollars
Jesus these people did their homework or
they made up a really great fake number
if you tally all the burglaries in your
country the total loss is in the
billions simply safe home security
protects every door in window in your
home but not the sky life that's a
window yes right okay home security you
get motion sensors entry sensors Tom
Cruise couldn't [ __ ] break into this
place simply safe system is completely
wireless you can set it up yourself with
simply safe there's no long-term
contracts or hidden fees and you have
professed a professional alarm
monitoring your place around the clock
ready to send the police that's just 15
bucks a month come on people go to
simply safer calm and get a special 10
percent discount when you order today or
if you want this secure security system
right away visit your local Best Buy
that simply saved bird calm for 10% off
simply save bird calm alright two more
hang in there hang in there Jolly's
shave club dude
when you might not know what you might
not know is that Dollar Shave Club also
has products for pretty much everything
else you need in the bathroom
wash shampoo hair gel lip balm
everything I've been to body wash ape
shampoo hair gel lip balm at the store
there are too many options I can't
figure it out and you can't tell the
difference between any of them how dumb
are you then if you have any questions
that clerk usually doesn't know the
difference or there's just one [ __ ]
person working there CVS or can't really
help you since they are not experts on
the products college dropouts Dollar
Shave Club makes it easy and convenient
for you to upgrade your shave and your
bathroom now you don't have to step foot
in a store and get a hike to get a high
quality I get what happened I can't read
anymore
now you don't have to step foot in a
store to get a high-quality shave and
grooming products Dollar Shave club's
delivers them right to your [ __ ] door
they go in there and they're high-fiving
the people that thought they meow
just like oh right their razors
everything is super high-quality and
will leave you looking and feeling
amazing if you're sick of nonsense of
the nonsense at the store now is the
time to try out Dollar Shave Club for a
limited time Dollar Shave Club is
basically giving away their [ __ ] shower
shave starter kit to new members for
only $5 this starter set features the
executive razor and three trial versions
three trial sized versions are the most
popular products that help you stay
fresh and clean so fresh it's so clean
if your first box in your first box you
will receive their shave butter body
wash and one wipe Charlies og re butt
wipes you will also receive the
executive razor which includes their
premium weighty handle and full cassette
of cartridges after the first box
replacement cartridges are sent for only
a few bucks a month this offers
exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / hey dollars
shake clubs high quality products have
you covered from face cheeks to butt
cheeks there is no better time to try
the club oh look who's here everybody oh
jesus here we go dodo dodo me andhis me
undies what happened to you the NFL doo
doo dude me undies me
I think it's going to the health why do
you gotta please everybody just have
people smash into each other who cares
why do you have to have a bunch of pink
a bunch of [ __ ] ladies there you know
what's the guys for it because we want a
theme progressive all right me undies
hey have you send a feminist a dick pic
that it has that but you have it in a
little pink sweater is that okay is that
considered progressive I don't know all
right me undies
you want to look good in your underwear
don't you you want to be comfortable
right but that perfect balance is hard
to find don't sacrifice style or comfort
check out my undies calm and find the
best pair of underwear in the world well
talk about why me undies is the best
underwear you'll ever own you know what
I love about it they sent it to me for
free it's nice and snug up against my
nuts you don't I mean but it's
affectionate it's not suffocating makes
my nuts feel safe and you know I got to
be honest with you before I met me
underneath I never felt that before the
undies will be the most comfortable pair
of underwear you will own made from a
sustainably sourced naturally soft
fabric that's three times softer than
cotton right now my undies has an
executive it has an exclusive offer for
just my listeners get 20% off your first
pair and free shipping and me undies is
so sure you will love their underwear
they even offer a 100% satisfaction
guarantee you you order a pair and if
you don't love your first pair get to
get a full refund this is a no-brainer
to try 20% off free shipping and 100
cents satisfaction guarantee what and
the [ __ ] are you waiting for to get you
20% off free shipping and then 100%
satisfaction guarantee and get the best
in softest underwear you will ever own
go to my undies calm / bird this is a
limited time offer so what are you
waiting for start wearing the best
underwear of your life it changed my
life evidently according to the copy
it's time to let me undies change yours
go to me undies calm slash / right now
okay that's the podcast I got to go do
the table read for episode 307 which
means season 3 episode 7 which I never
understood
ice be like what we're not on episode
307 oh great
computer falls to the floor that just
probably woke up my daughter is that my
daughter down there I'm sorry this thing
was so rushed and jumbled up but I'm
under a time [ __ ] thing here so I'm
not gonna keep babbling about it enjoy
the music and a half hour of greatest
hits from a Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
from a Thursday gone by and a year gone
past or maybe
[Music]
Frank Sinatra oh by the way by the way
is I'm all over the [ __ ] map here did
you [ __ ] see that shameless [ __ ]
Hillary Clinton trying to pander to get
the african-american vote she saw on
some radio show I just watched the clip
I had to shut it off forgive me I don't
know what radio show it is but she's
sitting there she goes and she's trying
to get the black vote and she they ask
you what's something you always carry
around with you and she said hot sauce
[Laughter]
but they the Clintons are the [ __ ] I
swear to god can't you just see both of
them on a used-car lot doing one of
those cheesy local commercials do they
have the [ __ ] devil
I remember when Hillary Clinton ran for
[ __ ] Senate after eight years of
being in the White House the [ __ ]
Yankees had won four World Series she
never showed up never said a [ __ ]
thing and then all of a sudden she's
running for [ __ ] Senate in New York
shows up with a brand new Yankee hat
goes I vow he's very Yankee fan that
this big grin like I said it now they're
gonna like me this is how out of touch
she is she literally thinks that she
just has to say I carry around hot sauce
and all black people would be like oh oh
[ __ ] oh I can relate to that what's she
gonna do next she's gonna go to [ __ ]
Chinatown which I always carry around
soy sauce
yeah go down south you know I love guns
and my cousin's sorry sorry I should
have said that um hot rods I've always
liked hot rods [ __ ] shameless this is
the thing about like when you're at her
level of [ __ ] wealth which is really
I don't know how you explain it you know
when her husband you know had the
highest office in public office and you
only is president you only make full
five hundred grand a year somehow they
threw that daughter a three million
dollar wedding I mean how does the math
work there they are the [ __ ] that she is
the [ __ ] devil I'm telling you you
know oh my god what a [ __ ] selection
this year can you [ __ ] believe this
[ __ ]
a reality show star you know who's
sitting there with that [ __ ] I don't
know what the other guy's name is
they're talking about the size of their
hands they having a size II a dick
debate running for office you got
Hillary you [ __ ] write it I'll say it
she doesn't give a [ __ ] this is what I
got to be honest with you why I like
Republicans better than Democrats
Republicans at least have the decency to
just show too openly show you that they
don't give a [ __ ] about you and
Democrats they actually try to act like
they give a [ __ ] how people about people
who work for a [ __ ] living they don't
they're the same [ __ ] people they
just lie about you know I swear to god
if Bernie Sanders would just [ __ ] go
the whole way you know what I mean don't
stop and cool wait you got to go all the
way to Baghdad with these [ __ ]
bankers okay that's what you got to do
you got to tip over the Statue and you
got to have all those top-level bankers
swinging at the end of a rope that's the
only way to see you got to start over
again
that's my candidate none of them are
saying that so it's over and I know you
think it bill you don't know [ __ ] and
you read conspiracy theory and you know
when I say too that you're absolutely
right okay all right let's move on that
was uh that was uh that was political
comedy right there if you if you're
wondering what that was supposed to be
it's ghost a little Italy what are you
always have in your purse a jar of man
Narus on who's your favorite singer Dean
Martin oh my god did you see the host
she looked like she rolled her eyes I
don't want to put like [ __ ] on her that
that's what she [ __ ] did that's not
what a touch she is Hillary Clinton
thinks black all black people walk
around with hot sauce in their purse
because white people don't know how to
season food I'm not saying there aren't
some black people through that you know
what I mean but you know that would also
be people who aren't white who look at
white people and think we're all in the
upper 1% standing on a yacht shooting
the [ __ ] with one of the Kennedys and
they're [ __ ] weird in Brent inbred
dentition I noticed of the Kennedys I
they they're from like the nose up
they're really good-looking people great
hair you know nice [ __ ] big five head
you know looks great on TV decent eyes
you know and then you just get to that
you get to those I mean it was kidding
oh they look like from the nose down
they look like Clint Howard I don't know
what it is
there's something going on with that
family you can't you notice is they
still look ethnic if you look at if you
look at like like white people from like
like look at Joe DiMaggio you know he's
probably considered a good-looking guy
that guy is [ __ ] dick I don't know
what happened once everybody got all
mixed up like all the [ __ ] Nationals
got mixed up like you know started
streamlining the look some people are
way better looking now don't you think
then when you look back in the day I
mean Jesus Christ babe rule everyone so
Lou Gehrig was a good-looking guy you
know what I mean but Babe Ruth that guy
was a mess Joe DiMaggio mess I guess
they were all bad looking I know I'm
just saying when you look at the [ __ ]
back then like an Italian guy looked a
hundred percent [ __ ] in town you know
something when I went to Italy they were
better look in the back then I don't
know what the [ __ ] it was we allegedly
had better food back then people were
shorter I don't know what I was do you
ever notice that when you look back and
when you really look at those old
pictures I love looking
pictures and it's like that George
Carlin bit when you look at an old
picture you like everybody in that
picture is dead and for some reason in a
morbid way it's like fascinating when I
look at those old pictures I just that's
what I think I god dammit there was some
[ __ ] ugly ass people you know and you
know as a game change it was uh three
things polio vaccine penicillin and
braces those three [ __ ] things could
just hide so many [ __ ] imperfections
you know what I mean
I won't you get braces Jesus Christ if
you just brush your [ __ ] teeth and
remotely keep yourself in shape you know
you throw on some nice clothes people
have no idea where you came from you
know back in the day people they saw it
on you
your teeth told the whole [ __ ] story
you'd smile of you like I I can see
you're gonna have to parochial OSIS you
live in a damp dank [ __ ] apartment
with no [ __ ] windows you saw it in
their [ __ ] teeth right
I don't nobody heard what's-his-face JP
Morgan had like rosacea though so you
say they had it all over his face he was
just all [ __ ] angry those old school
which guys you know I used to walk
around with top hats it's like the
penguin walking down the street is this
a podcast anymore yeah I mean what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about let me let me do
something advertising here and then I'll
I'll get two more babbling here in a
moment all right
hot sauce
shameless [ __ ] shameless she looks
inbred to her [ __ ] teeth there's
something going on with her and this sub
girl you see how Bill Clinton collapsed
now it's like he's like a marionette
puppet he has his mouth open uh that's
how he made it let that smiling with his
mouth open oh I've gotta fix it I'm
gonna fix everything
how you doing call me later
[Music]
I'm sick of Obama's wife yeah this isn't
some Republican rant either it's just
kind of first ladies in general you know
I don't know what it is all throughout
my life with each presidency like these
first ladies they've just gotten more
and more like like like chatty
you know no more chiming in like leaning
into the frame spitting out their ideas
it's just like well why are you talking
right
you weren't elected shut up your
husband's not running a lemonade stand
here he's running the country
it'll just chime in let me guess is this
considered sexist why oh okay you're
just not at that lady let me ask you
this all right let's say you had a leak
in your house okay you call a plumber up
he shows up and he goes yeah I think the
leaks coming from the upstairs bathroom
we need to shut it off the but then all
of a sudden his wife walks in who is it
a plumber
take his Caravan hey would you be like
with all due respect shut the [ __ ] up
[Applause]
[Music]
I like sending Olive Branch here alright
at some point there's gonna be the first
female president right which means at
that moment you're gonna have the first
male first lady right and when that
happens that too needs to shut his trap
I don't want to hear a word out of them
I want to hear from the president you
sir go do some first lady stuff
all right go get yourself some clothes
fit go up to your elbows smile and nod
during speeches go put your own Flair
redecorate in the White House
hike which leads you to Michelle Obama
right now she's sitting there holding up
those hashtags from that hashtag bring
back our girls remember that it's like I
could get blew my mind it's like why are
you showing me that I'm a stand-up
comedian like what am I gonna do to get
those girls back why don't you look
across the dinner table it's like you
see that guy
[Applause]
the leader of the free world tell him to
pick up a phone call some Navy SEALs and
solve it what what am I gonna do show up
at the sharpen mic stand
oh it's unreal
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll tell you what kills me Hillary
Clinton might run she might she might
run that blows mine I mean as she became
a senator she went from being the
president's wife to being a senator just
like that lateral move
that's like Tom Brady's wife's become
the next quarterback of the ramps it's
like what you hanging out you just pick
it up I sucked at sports and then I bang
Tom Brady and I don't know what happened
I just picked up a ball I started liking
it leading receivers was incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
I knew it was gonna be like this hey
what's going on is Bill Burr and this is
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
September 14 2009
it's like [ __ ] 10:20 at night I
finally got some time to do the podcast
today I was flying back from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
I lost my cell phone you know once again
I lost another cell phone every time I
get a nice cell phone I lose him so I
just reactivated my little flip phone
those of you who go on to Bill burr comm
when you listen to my podcast you see
that picture me right there looking down
at the bar and that little 15 year old
chick flip phone that I got there that's
what I'm back to I went from a
blackberry to that thing you know you
know just once I would like to lose a
[ __ ] phone and call it and have
someone on the other end be my savior be
like why yes yes I have found your phone
and I would love to return it to you
there is nothing more I would like to do
than return it's you know free of charge
free of charge that's what happens
everybody else I know any time my
girlfriend loses her cell phone she
calls up she just you know oh my god I
left my cell phone and then she just
picks up Mike she goes let me use your
phone and she just goes you know it
rings like twice and it's always the
nicest person ever on the other line
she's like hey yeah yeah that's mine oh
thank you oh that's awesome okay great
okay right and then I'm driving her
somewhere to go pick the [ __ ] thing
up
that never happens for me it just rings
and rings and rings and then I just hear
my voicemail hey this is Bill you've
reached my cellphone that you're never
gonna [ __ ] see again please leave a
message and you might want to call
provide you know call
and Verizon and have it shut off before
somebody calls Trinidad on this goddamn
thing
[ __ ] so that was my day this how old I
am - you know what when I was flying out
here there was there was nobody sitting
next to me and actually he was fell
asleep you know laying down on the row
and when I woke up like I felt like my
lower body dislocated from my upper body
it wasn't even like my back hurt it was
just like I felt like I got hit by a
[ __ ] car it's been a brutal days what
I'm trying to say people blow me weekend
in Philly was awesome so many people
showed up so many people showed up we
added a show that's never happened to me
you know so I want to thank everybody
before I get going on this long rambling
podcast here I want to thank everybody
in Philadelphia who came out to see me I
had a great time and I was working there
with Joe DeRosa the teen idol the new
hotshot teen idol on the Opie and
Anthony show was opening up for me and
oh my god did the Raiders just score a
[ __ ] touchdown is there no flag holy
[ __ ] are they finally gonna beat the
Chargers okay I don't to ruin you guys
who anybody TiVoed the [ __ ] game they
just went up 1917 with 234 left you know
it's funny I was supposed to have a bet
you know I'm a Patriots fan and I was
supposed to bet these guys shred and
Reagan out in Buffalo right I made him a
$50 bet last year when Tom Brady went
down that the Patriots are gonna make
the playoffs because they were saying
that they were done so if the Patriots
didn't make the playoffs I on both fifty
bucks but if I won they had to read a
written apology to Bill Belichick that I
wrote and they had to read it on the air
we went 11 and 5 but we didn't make it
so I owed him 50 bucks but I never went
to Buffalo and I could never pay him so
lo and behold the first game of the
season
we're playing Buffalo so I go hey let's
go double or nothing you know and they
wouldn't touch it they would not touch
the [ __ ] game on air I was like - the
worst you could do is break even and
then they still they still wouldn't back
their own team and look at the [ __ ]
game actually home
wanted they actually did win it they
just blew the game but uh so I'm glad
I'm glad I saved myself fifty bucks each
shred and Reagan if you listen to this
you guys punked out and you know it's
funny was when I got off the plane I
actually got a message from one of the
guys who works there trying to get me to
call in at the last second I bet a lot
of their listeners called them punks for
not taking the bet and unfortunately I'd
lost my cell phone or I would have
called in but it worked out for me
um I'm too [ __ ] frazzled to do this
guys I really am I can't [ __ ] do this
but I got to get this done cuz I got too
much [ __ ] to do tomorrow usually and I
enjoy doing the podcast it's usually in
the morning I'm usually screaming and
I'm having a good [ __ ] time but now
it's late my dog's asleep my downstairs
neighbors asleep downstairs neighbor
doesn't like us we have hardwood floors
and my girlfriend has high-heeled shoes
so you can do the math on that one let's
just get let's just cut to the chase you
guys mind if I do a short one this week
yeah well to [ __ ] bed let me let me
give you some happy [ __ ] because this
isn't gonna be happy I'm [ __ ]
exhausted let me give you some YouTube
videos to watch this week all right this
first one I stumbled across because
someone else showed me something else
this video what you want to search is it
says try not to laugh or say WTF
basically what the [ __ ] but you just
write WTF all lowercase
try not to laugh or say WTF and I'm have
a feeling a lot of women won't find it
funny because it's just really like
you'd have to be in the seventh grade or
a male to find this funny
I can't even explain while it's why it's
funny but it just makes me laugh my ass
off but it's it's a great video because
you will either laugh or you will say
what the [ __ ]
here's another one somebody sent me
search gay Top Gun the guys ever seen
the movie Top Gun and you've seen
Tarantino go on his rent that it's
actually a
homo erotic movie the way this person
edits it is [ __ ] hilarious
and I haven't seen the movie oh my god I
probably haven't seen that movie since
the late 80s you know I member I so did
I see in the movie theaters no I think
somebody bought it somebody my family
bought that movie that was actually
considered a good movie you know and you
know we had it on VHS so you know the
usual life of a VHS tape it lasted like
a [ __ ] year then it was all screwed
up from being rewound you know so I
haven't seen it basically since I would
have 89 or 90 and I got to go with
Tarantino on that one
and at least the way this guy edits the
movie man it's [ __ ] and it's really
funny all right the last YouTube video
you might want to check out and this one
and I'm just search dance kick baby all
right a comedian last night where I
worked a very funny guy told me to Jeff
and I've already forgot his last [ __ ]
name of such a [ __ ] he was hilarious so
he told me to check this one out
dance kick baby it's it's I can't say
it's funny it'll definitely make you put
your hand over your mouth because it's
not dance kick baby it's not that it's
dancing and then a baby gets kicked all
right you want you everyone see what
happens when a toddler gets [ __ ] just
check it out all right there's a lot of
sick [ __ ] are gonna look at that one
first like I said this is gonna be real
economical economical whatever the [ __ ]
you say it this week let's plow ahead
here's some advice somebody wants listen
to this story this one really this one
really grabbed me here on a lot of
levels all right bill asked bill bill I
was at a family birthday party today
when some friends of mine friends of my
dads showed up with their smoking-hot
daughter making after making a few
glances at each other I figured I had a
good chance of getting her number I went
over to her my dad introduced us we made
a little small talk her mom then asked
if she wanted a piece of cake or
anything so I decided to be a [ __ ]
gentleman
and offer to get her a piece so I come
back with the slice of cake in hand only
to see my brother and he's written this
in capital letters so you know this
isn't gonna go anywhere good
he goes I come back only to see my
brother capital letters talking to her
and already getting her number on the
guys that she's interested in getting
into law enforcement and he happens to
be a cop
that pretty much cancelled me out since
there's no way I was gonna pull the same
[ __ ] in which both brothers asked her
for her number yeah that would have been
creepy so he goes I handed the cake and
the three of us talk some more until her
parents decided to leave since it was
towards the end of the party already
after that after they left I immediately
told my brother you know walked up to my
brother and I told him what the [ __ ]
since everybody could tell I was trying
to get her number he joked along with my
what is that un des I don't know what
that word means
he told my uncles I couldn't read that
sorry this volumes up way too high here
let me turn this thing down sorry record
level
I don't know I don't know how to [ __ ]
do that on the fly do I does that work
that's better
hello no it's still [ __ ] up all right
whatever I'll hold them Michael wait for
me told you guys this one's gonna be
brutal I'm exhausted anyway so he goes
yes like went up to him I said what the
[ __ ]
since everyone could tell I was trying
to get a number he joked along with my
uncle's saying she's 26 and I guess he's
20 and his brother the cop is 21 so he
choked her with his uncle said come on
man she's 26 she's out of your league
and that he beat me to it
I figured yeah I guess he did and didn't
so he I did make a big deal or anything
after that since I'm not a little [ __ ]
who's gonna cry about it I'm gonna cry
about some twice number however I still
thought it was [ __ ] up if it had been
the other way around I would have just
let my brother do his thing I guess it
comes down to the bar scene where if you
step away to get a [ __ ] a drink you're
leaving the field pretty much open for
anybody else I don't know do you think
it was a [ __ ] up move or just part of
the game thanks and hope to see you on
stage soon um well what do I think about
that ah all right I don't want to blame
the victim here but what I learned in
that letter is that your brother's kind
of a dick you know that's kind of a dick
move and you know I wouldn't done that
to my brother but you know he's doing it
to you that that's that's a dick move
and you live with the guy so you know
he's a dick
you don't I mean and you kind of answer
the question yeah you never you never
leave first of all even if you know even
if he didn't come over you're already
setting up the relationship that you
know you're just gonna be fetching her
stuff offering her you know
are you cold you want me to get you a
blanket you know you don't be that guy
you know your brother out
I really want to make fun of the fact
that he'd went the law enforcement hey
let me teach you how to be a cop all
right this is how you frisk somebody you
know but believe me you use what you got
you think I have never met a [ __ ]
good-looking girl and I said you know
worked away in that I was a comedian and
invited her to a show her and one of her
friends hoping desperately she would
only show up by herself so I could try
and [ __ ] bang her so I can't get mad
at him for that yeah in the future I I
would just I just wouldn't do that [ __ ]
around your brother that's a really
[ __ ] thing and I think you need to
get him back somehow I want to I want a
story of revenge from you that's what I
want but the end of the day do the
chicks [ __ ] 26 years old and you know
she's got a 21 year old trying to figure
out her future you know she's a loser
and Plus you know just the way you were
talking about it you know I learned a
you know you never leave a [ __ ] alone
you just wanted to [ __ ] her anyways
right so whatever lesson learned lesson
learned and to use the top gun analogy
your brother is not he's not a wingman
he's not a good wingman so [ __ ] that guy
and
I don't know you know she could do this
is something nice to do way back in a
day when I was in Boston and I used to
go to this place Daisy Buchanan's on
Newbury Street which was a total [ __ ]
meat market and I'm sure it still is I
used to go in there with uh with a
couple friends of mine and we you know
going there you know have a couple
drinks and just start talking [ __ ] to
girls or whatever trying to [ __ ] hook
up cuz God knows that's easy to have
three guys that's always a nice magic
number no wonder we never hooked up but
we used to go in there and I figured
well use call it droppin bombs I can't
remember what it was but basically you
wouldn't [ __ ] block but she would
definitely [ __ ] with your friend if he
was you'd see him hitting on a girl and
it was going well
you'd walk up to him and you would just
make up some detail about his life that
would be embarrassing that he would have
to somehow play off unless she got
serious and you really got mad like a
buddy of mine did one time and mentioned
that a friend of mine was still living
in the basement with his mom that's what
he said he had just got done striking
out so then he came walking up all
hammered and he's like oh yeah this guy
was [ __ ] this guy was one of these
dudes you know those guys who like who
look up at the ceiling when they're
talking he was one of those guys and he
just came walking up and that's what he
said
he goes oh yeah yeah you like this guy
yeah he did you mention that you still
live at home
he said it really angry you know what
else this guy did that's a classic story
I can't believe my never [ __ ] told us
we went Daisy Buchanan's one night right
it was just one of those nights you know
I don't know what we were talking the
women were responding we were like holy
[ __ ] this is going great
for once cuz believe me we did not do
well it's a reason I had to get on a
stage and act like a jackass okay so I
don't know what have I met this group of
girls and it was going great and we all
having a good time and everybody kind of
paired off everybody was vibing right
and all of a sudden you just felt the
whole energy energy of the bar just look
towards the front door it was like
somebody you know famous or something
was going on you know like what all of a
sudden there's like a commotion
everybody just looks in that direction
right so it was weird everybody just
sort of collectively looked at the doors
like a wave that went across the room
second everybody felt the energy he just
looked in the direction you felt the
energy coming from and we look over at
the door and I swear to God
what the [ __ ] just happened San Diego
just scored Jesus Christ [ __ ] Raiders
goddamn [ __ ] guys just can they ever
beat San Diego all right let me plow
ahead so they [ __ ] everybody just
goes and looks at the door and we look
over and there's this guy dressed like
Elvis [ __ ] Elvis impersonator this is
the most bizarre [ __ ] block I ever got
this guy's standing of course like fat
Elvis some comic did that joke nobody
nobody ever dresses up like the in shape
Elvis because no one was ever that
good-looking they always dressed like
the fat one or something like that right
so everybody said fat Elvis he's got the
[ __ ] you know right before he
overdosed on pills sunglasses on and he
was doing all like these moves to
whatever music was on and he [ __ ]
like every girl in the bar was like oh
my god they all [ __ ] ran over to the
guy right so it was like everything was
going great we're thinking we're gonna
hook up and next thing you know [ __ ]
fake Elvis walks in and the girls just
run away and they all run up to the guy
cuz they don't want to get like their
picture taken with them a [ __ ]
whatever so every guy in the bar were
kind of standing like out do do you [ __ ]
you gotta be kidding me right so my
buddy who looks up at the ceiling he is
he walks up to the guy you know and the
guy standing up there meeting everybody
what's up man how you doing all right
all right taking care of business how
you doing buddy he like doing the Elvis
thing he's got the [ __ ] leg shakin
and everything so my buddy goes up there
right and he starts shaking the guy's
hand he's like what's up man
my buddy's like squeezing his hand right
and he's looking up at the ceiling but
the fake Elvis can tell he's pissed he's
like what what's the matter man and my
buddy's just like he goes hey dude he's
like squeezing his hand he goes hey
buddy why can't you just be yourself you
know he's like looking up the ceiling
because why can't you just be yourself
you know he goes I'd like the Red Sox I
don't come in here dressed like Roger
Clemens and the guys like going he's
kind of draw
and character going alright man alright
dude alright alright that his voice has
changed and they start having this
[ __ ] handshake fight squeezing each
other's hands and they were about ready
to go at it and at that point I was like
I was gonna see the greatest thing ever
because my buddy was big I was like if
he [ __ ] punches his fake Elvis and I
see those plastic glasses helicopter off
of his [ __ ] face ah please let him be
wearing a wig and right before they did
it was like you ever see like an NHL
game when the ref steps in right before
two goons are gonna go at it
the guy [ __ ] broke it up but it was
still good my pony had a [ __ ]
handshake fight with Elvis impersonator
and really just broke the guy down
that's what I loved everybody's like oh
my god Elvis what's going on I thought
you died no man I'm always a lob he's
just playing along oh my god let me get
a picture okay honey you know he's doing
all that [ __ ] no my buddy just comes up
hey dude why can't you just be yourself
oh [ __ ] those were some drunk days
alright let's plow ahead what the [ __ ]
was I talking about yeah you know what
dude two things I would tell you when
your brother first of all don't [ __ ]
hit on women you're around your [ __ ]
kunti brother and if he does pull some
[ __ ] like that you know you got to do
something that you that's what you got
to do to that guy what you have to do is
the next time he's hitting on a girl you
have to deliberately go over and [ __ ] it
up you got to figure out some way to
[ __ ] it up and what you're doing here is
you kind of shootin one across the bow
just to let him know that if he does
that [ __ ] to you again that there will
be like repercussions you don't I mean
and then just get the [ __ ] away from the
guy and continue on you know you're
doing fine right
you had no problem walking up to the
girl you had a strategy you're good but
yeah there's no there's no sense dude
you're 20 years old man you're in
[ __ ] mint condition you don't need
some [ __ ] 26 year-old when you do
with that right I know you'd [ __ ] her
exactly but you're not gonna marry it
right you don't have any feelings for
her so [ __ ] [ __ ] her and [ __ ] your
brother [ __ ] 20-year 21-year old cop
cop we're at the mall how did he how
long do you have to go to school to be a
cop
you know anybody else have that like you
went to there's a kid in the grade above
you and he's like the biggest maniac
ever and then you become a senior and
next thing you know he's coming in he's
breaking up keg parties you know like
dude I was in shop class with you six
months ago no I'm a police officer now
Wow well full-on you got the gun and
everything I think I just missed a
[ __ ] unbelievable game doing this
goddamn podcast it was two scores late
in the game you know what I hate about
football I hate how they always show the
douchebags who dress up like they're
going to the Rocky Horror Picture Show
you know what I mean I went to a Raiders
game not everybody is dressed like a
douchebag and make no mistake
those are douche bags okay those people
who [ __ ] make a hat out of a football
you know they did it to Patriots game -
I was joking with my buddy ago can't
they just show some regular fan who
looks like he has season tickets it
could actually talk about the game this
guy had like a you know silver glitter
on his face with the Patriots humble
people wearing football helmets to the
game you know it's almost like the guy
in the TV truck is just telling the
camera man just find the biggest
douchebag you can find that's who we're
gonna show I went to I went to a Raiders
game up a couple years ago man it was
great you know just a legendary place
even though it's been a while since
they've had a lot of success they didn't
go to his Super Bowl gets Tampa Bay a
few years ago but I actually met this
older guy man he had like the Ken
Stabler silver and white beard had some
booze on his breath you know he's a
football fan [ __ ] wasn't sitting
there dressed like Boba Fett it's
[ __ ] dumb I hate people do that [ __ ]
all right let's plow ahead here all
right bill
I was bored and thought I might give you
something to think about I live in
Europe and would love to move to the US
but I have no idea how to even apply or
even if it's a good time to do it I'm 30
and I've been stalling for years but I
don't want to pack a bag and just end up
as some homeless guy in the corner
in America I've always loved New York as
the idea as the idea of this death city
what as the idea of a city that never
sleeps fits me as I'm a little older now
I've already seen most of my friend
friends leave into the domestic
lifestyle and I just can't fit into that
yet I spent a lot of time alone for a
few years and it's just like your act
you start going a little crazy
I feel like an observer in life so I do
and say stuff just to see what happens
sometimes what a big sorry I'm scrolling
down here would be a good ground would
that be a good ground for comedy maybe
or should I have started in my 20s I
also play guitar and people have said I
might have something musically for years
but I was always a coward in my youth
and couldn't get on stage unless I was
hammered so I never got anywhere now I'm
worried I lost too many screws and as my
social network has begun failing I just
get the bitter alone against the word
world feeling it feels like I'm at a
crossroads everything I've seen in life
seems like a weird dream and I'm
surrounded by strangers what do you
think I think that's pretty [ __ ] deep
what is well if you're not married you
don't have any kids and you want to
always wanted to move to New York just
[ __ ] do it save up some money and
just do it you're never gonna regret you
know well if you live in America and
you're like I always want to go to Paris
what would happen if I just [ __ ] went
there do it the very least you're just
gonna get some great stories you know
you're gonna come over wherever you
gonna go you're gonna have an accent
you're gonna hook up it's gonna be a
good time I would definitely say to go
and don't mind [ __ ] yourself into
thinking you're too old to do [ __ ] look
failing the how do we put this failing
is like overrated as far as like the
pain that people have it's not doing it
cuz I have a lot of [ __ ] regrets in
life I got a lot of [ __ ] regrets I'm
not gonna get into him but I got a lot
of [ __ ] regrets and I've failed a lot
as a comedian but none of them really
hurt because I
just kept doing it you know remember
that old Michael Jordan commercial where
he talks about shooting the basketballs
all the shots he's missed he was like I
failed over and over and over and over
again and that's why I succeed you got
to take that mentality
dude failing is [ __ ] hilarious
failing is it's the best stories it's
the funniest [ __ ] stories watch one
people when actors go and they do panel
on talk shows they never talk about you
know oh I did this the bad guests go on
there and talk I work with this director
oh my god he was so great but the good
guests go on there and they talk about
bad auditions that they had or stupid
things that they did in the great movie
that they're promoting that's what the
[ __ ] you do you know to kill as a guest
look at me I'm a little tired I'm making
a different point now now I'm telling
you how to kill doing panel even though
I've never [ __ ] done it um
yeah dude moved in New York you're not
gonna be homeless it's like a big river
and you just jump in it and you just
start swimming but from the outside it
looks impossible but once you go there
you find you know and if you do end up
homeless fortunately it's a walkable
city so there's plenty of people to
Panhandle although if you're white you
might have a rough time at least I did
did it one day as a joke just to see
what people would do I was dressed
really nicely I just had a cup excuse me
sir sir could you spare a little change
just trying to get home trying to make a
phone call but I had a shit-eating grin
so I didn't make any money all right
next question
yeah I'm plowing ahead this week people
all right hey Bill I'm a huge fan thank
you thank you very much all right you
won't be after this low energy podcast
throughout my life no matter what I've
done I am known for being a horrible
child all right guys let's stop here
just let's just remember that I barely
got out of college and I have a
communications degree so let me
communicate with you right now and let
you know that I if you guys are gonna go
real deep cuz I had somebody set me like
one they were like suicidal and I kind
of didn't touch it because I didn't want
to give the wrong advice I was gonna say
go talk to somebody quite qualified you
know and don't kill yourself
all right so let's try it let's you know
let's let's back off the throttle a
little bit here people this is supposed
to be a funny podcast all right they're
like I just walking around feeling like
it's a dream and I'm alone you know I
that's when it starts getting like all
right I've had those thoughts well I
guess I've had those thoughts so I can
relate you know I've thought about
killing myself a lot of people think
that [ __ ] you just don't do it you don't
I mean it's like legsweep and a chick
you think about it you just don't do it
but if someone makes a video of it you
[ __ ] watch it and it's hilarious
all right let's plow through her
throughout my life no matter what I've
done I have always been known for being
a horrible child all right this guy's
gotten right to the root of his pain no
matter what I did it wasn't good enough
I think I'm pretty and I feel bad cuz
I'm you're making fun of people as if
[ __ ] really opening up here so let me
stop doing that all right I think I'm a
pretty good kid compared to the people I
know my grades aren't that good but hey
I haven't gotten held back well there's
a positive way of looking at it you got
a D in math yeah did I stay back well I
right then shut the [ __ ] up I'm 15 and I
have an older brother two years older
and I have a younger brother two years
younger the younger one is annoying so
if he starts bothering me I say
something to him telling him to stop oh
when I do that I'm being a dick
what I'm being a dick when I could just
slap him or something and then he does
the classic [ __ ] and screams like
clockwork and my parents will come in
and punish me oh yeah do it I've been
there
I had three younger brothers I've been
there if he was bothering me first if he
they punish you if he was even bothering
you first but what you got to do is you
got to muffle his voice with a pillow oh
you can go the opposite route is you can
torch room by tickling them is basically
you sit on their arms and you do the
typewriter thing you know what I mean
there's a lot of other ways to make
obviously the slap isn't gonna work
because he knows he's gonna get you in
trouble that way so you got to come up
with creative ways to torture your
younger brother start with doing it when
your parents aren't home all right
why am I telling people to do this [ __ ]
all right ah at some point they need to
stop babying him instead of taking his
side because he's the youngest and then
there's my somewhat perfect older
brother who was always in the limelight
I admit I'm jealous
I mean he makes on a roll plays football
and works all at the same time and I'm
just the [ __ ] in the middle why is the
middle kid always feel [ __ ] neglected
I guess cuz you're in the middle I was
you know second oldest I don't know
where the [ __ ] I was he has always been
treated better than me his best friend
got him in trouble for for lighting
trash cans on fire back when he was in
the seventh grade and my dad cursed him
out and told him to never hang cursed
out the other kid and told him not to
hang out with my older brother again
what happens in the 12th grade they're
hanging out again and my parents don't
say [ __ ] I have a bad friend and I
haven't even gotten in trouble with him
but my parents won't let me hang out
with them my parents let my older
brother learn how to drive when he was
12 and I'm turning 16 and they haven't
taught me [ __ ] I probably won't get a
damn license until I'm 25
then they treat me like [ __ ] last week I
cleaned my bathroom and left uh my mini
trash cans sitting outside the bathroom
and instead of being glad they go ape
because I leave the trash can outside
the bedroom please tell me what you
think about this situation yeah you're
getting the middle child treatment you
get in the middle child treatment this
is what I would say beat up your younger
brother when your parents aren't around
or maybe break some of his [ __ ] when
he's not in his room and your older
brother you can cut the brake lines on
his car now I'm [ __ ] with you
um hey you know what [ __ ] them [ __ ] em
if they don't want to pay attention to
you [ __ ] them just keep doing your thing
and make a joke out of it you know you
know you left a trash can outside the
bathroom I know what was I thinking
I should have been like my older brother
and lit it on fire you're absolutely
right at what point ma did you realize
you were bored with me huh
when the newer version of me came along
and then when she tries to interrupt
just Vietnam dad dad I get it you don't
care you don't I'm the middle kid what
do you think I don't watch The Brady
Bunch
I saw what Jen went through I'm going
through the same [ __ ] then
about driving huh how bad a driver was
my older brother that you just decided
not to teach any of us you know I don't
know just go with that route but but you
know Bob of all don't take it personally
just focus on your own life you got
understand you're probably walking
around 15 you know you know you're at
that age where you kind of think you
know some [ __ ] but you kind of know that
you don't know a lot of other [ __ ] that
that feeling never goes away and your
parents are walking around thinking the
same [ __ ] so don't take them too
seriously you know unless they tell you
you know not to do drugs or hang out
with that douche bag you probably
shouldn't be hanging out with them but
you know what I mean I don't I don't
know what to tell you dude it's like
that [ __ ] that you're gonna get through
it gets better when you're in your 20s
you know and you never know your brother
might have peaked that I'm still a lot
of people you know if they're getting
[ __ ] late in high school like do you
understand how great your life is if
you're actually on the football team and
you're [ __ ] a cheerleader and in high
school I mean I don't know how you ever
beat that you have to become like a
[ __ ] movie star like there's nowhere
for those people to go that's why so
many of those people they they when they
go out in the real world they they they
they fail because they they've always
been
king of the world you're on a football
team you're banging a cheerleader right
you're both in your teens your bodies
are in mint [ __ ] condition and you
don't have to pay rent and if you do
some dumb [ __ ] you're still charged as a
juvenile I'm gonna tell you right now
it's never gonna get better than that
okay are you gonna go a long [ __ ] away
as an adult to make it better than that
okay so you know I don't know if I'm
cheering you up here but you know being
in the middle being in that mix is not a
bad [ __ ] thing being in the middle of
her cuz then you can break out you can
try to figure out what you want to do
and then the fact that people kind of
[ __ ] on you you get a good sense of
humor you already wrote some funny [ __ ]
you'll be fine you know [ __ ] your older
brother and your younger brother what do
you think about that I know what to tell
you dude I just want to [ __ ] you up dude
I don't all right I don't have the
background to give a 15 year old [ __ ]
advice I really don't but I hope I made
some sort of sense but don't take it too
seriously
all right you know what I would do I
would always clean the bathroom and
always leave the trash can out there
just to deliberately annoy your parents
and then act slightly [ __ ] to the
point that they actually think back to
some drugs that they did when they was
single and that's why you're [ __ ] up
now you know do some [ __ ] like that just
passive aggressive stuff start having
fun with the fact that they don't pay
attention to you in other words act out
that's what I'm trying to say all right
so let's recap break your younger
brothers [ __ ] cut the brake lines on
your older brother's car ignore your
parents and act slightly [ __ ] all
right that's my advice oh here's
something for you I got good I wrote out
I got good feedback from a woman I don't
get this very often it's at a bill just
wanted to comment on your response to
the guy who got shot down at the
sandwich shop a couple weeks ago that
was a loaded question and for what it's
worth from a female fan I thought your
answer was incredibly fair as well as
funny it is [ __ ] that men generally
have the burden of approaching women and
I know that burned is asked to have her
look at him like a disgusting chore but
just because she's pretty doesn't mean
she owes everybody whoever tits on her a
[ __ ] thank-you card I really
appreciate your answer you could have
gone a much easier and
shittier rube Thanks yeah you mean like
how we did with the 15 year old kids
question all right every once in a while
I get positive feedback feedback from a
female so I got to read it all right
next one I'm just gonna read this like a
book this week people I am literally
nodding off here ass bill hey Bill
throughout my life no matter what I've
done did I already read this
are you read this one right Jesus Christ
all right oh here's some letters from my
people overseas specifically England
this section is called English [ __ ] hey
Bill so you thought my last email wasn't
good enough for your podcast I hold no
grudges it's a recession and you want to
keep it all American Fair Play
so let's keep up the theme from your
last one in attempt to get a mention
shameless whoring of myself here you say
baseball jump the shark let me tell you
something coming from the nation that
pretty much invent invented all major
sports except the Olympics Great Britain
you know I like to consider myself
knowledgeable about sports exactly what
sports did you create what sports did
you create you can do the rugby thing
and then rugby developed into football
I'll give you that one
that that was the spawn of it but you
can't take credit for baseball what do
you say that's cricket you guys sit
there with that fraternity paddle from
some horrific night of hazing you
finally pulled it out of some freshman's
ass and now you trying to hit a
racquetball over to some guy from
[ __ ] India huh what what other sports
have you guys invented basketball you
didn't invent that I don't know what you
guys invented but you sure suck at all
of them you know ones the last time you
guys want a World Cup
you know what that's a great [ __ ]
question that's what you guys are known
for soccer right and rugby like when
those douche bags over in England try to
they always try to say that that
football players are [ __ ] because
they wear like helmets and that type of
[ __ ] and then you watch a rugby game
those guys are tough but those guys
would be hitting each other a lot
[ __ ] harder if they had pads on and
[ __ ] you know I watch the game yeah it's
a bunch of guys [ __ ] sticking their
heads up each other's asses as they're
kicking at a football
that's definitely I don't you know
what's funny is I never disrespect rugby
I look at it like that that's a tough
sport and tough guys play that sport I
don't know why they always pick on
football I don't get it you know what I
mean
don't Ray Lewis would [ __ ] up at least
five of your rugby players by himself
without pads you got nobody in your
[ __ ] little [ __ ] ass English rugby
league that looks anything like Ray
Lewis let Ray Lewis would destroy him
Jack Lambert why don't you bring them
bring me your famous [ __ ] rugby guys
and show me how those guys are hitting
any harder than Lawrence Taylor
you're out of your [ __ ] mind how do
you [ __ ] mind let's look up England
England World Cup victory I'm gonna make
a guess and I'm gonna say it's it's
somewhere it's got to be the 1960s over
for England World Cup victory the World
Cup victory by England 1966 there you go
I [ __ ] knew it I knew it was gonna be
back then like when the Celtics were
winning all their championships right
was Brazil not allowed in back then
[ __ ] Pat in your stats I'm just
[ __ ] with you guys I respect your
sports but I you know what we pretty
much invented all major sports except
the Olympics go [ __ ] yourself you guys
an invention yet a half-assed idea that
we made tremendous is there and you know
what I mean like the greatest [ __ ]
soccer player of all time he's is he
from England it's Pele the Michael
Jordan of soccer is not even from
England so why don't you guys dominate
something on a world [ __ ] level
I want what what was last time you guys
had an athlete now cuz I'll tell you
right now that good-looking son of a
[ __ ] for the LA Galaxy is not doing
[ __ ] and nobody gives a [ __ ] about him
over here you can walk up and buy a
ticket alright
I went to an LA Galaxy [ __ ] game I
parked right next to the guy I don't
even recognize him I asked him which way
the [ __ ] stadium was the only reason
why I knew he was on the [ __ ] galaxy
cuz he already has [ __ ] cleats on
alright he can't wait to go back there
um all right - [ __ ] Bob Beckham all
right let me let me get back to this
[ __ ] thing I think I come from some
authority
oh yeah once you pat yourself on the
back a little more your English [ __ ]
here we go
baseball always [ __ ] sucked no it
didn't and I'll tell you why
it's a game suited for America like no
other hours of time to kill between
meaningful play meaningful for some
reason is two words meaning full like
what is the meaning of the word and I
ate too much I'm full meaningful is one
word yet dumb [ __ ] take the last L off
the full and smash them together Jesus I
hope that's right I just made an ass out
of myself between meaningful play
allowing for required TV advertising and
selling of [ __ ] overpriced food and poor
beer oh Jesus Christ really you don't
have any advertising there there's
advertising all over the advertising on
the [ __ ] ball in England you know
what maybe if you guys scored more than
once every [ __ ] 90 minutes you know
what I mean you could stick some
commercials in there Jesus Christ
the soccer is like hockey without the
skates and the scoring and the fighting
and everything that makes it great you
ever see like a little [ __ ] get tripped
out and out in a during recess and he
rolls around on the ground and makes
such a big [ __ ] deal out of it you
want to beat him with his own books
that's what like watching soccer is like
every five seconds these guys they look
like if Pau Gasol if you could have like
whatever 20 paga Saul's all in the same
[ __ ] field just bitching moaning with
that cry-baby [ __ ] face that's what
soccer is see what you did dude I
actually really enjoy the game but
you're attacking my shits and I'm gonna
attack yours minimal athleticism
required yeah dude really hitting up
baseball is one of the hardest thing you
ever do why don't you [ __ ] brush your
teeth and give it a chance at some point
you guys are swinging with that big
[ __ ] paddle oh god all right let me
go you know what I would never make fun
of the bicycle kick and act like that's
a simple thing to do anyways and before
you come up with this stock
we'd like to see you face a
hundred-mile-an-hour curve I just did
that that's hilarious
from insert drugged up goon here and
then talk that [ __ ] it's a game not a
sport like bowling is a game
now it isn't I can see ya bowling is a
game it's just you standing there if
somebody was throwing the bowling ball
at your head at a hundred miles an hour
and it was [ __ ] changing speeds then
that would be a sport okay or if you
just held the ball like t ball you just
hit it off a stand then it would just be
that would just be a game I don't know
athlete athletes are people who actually
move around for the majority of the
sport cyclist rowers even soccer players
cover around 10k per game Oh God
really is that why they were all built
like women you know what your athletes
look like in [ __ ] England they look
like mannequins at the gap you know I
know we're fat over here but we're more
muscular - you [ __ ] pansies over
there with your poor nutrition in your
nationwide health care plan why don't
you get some [ __ ] protein in your
diets these skinny ass [ __ ] arms and
your little legs running around not
being able to you know why you can't use
your [ __ ] hands in soccer cuz you
[ __ ] would break your wrists alright
that was homophobic sorry about that
didn't mean to say [ __ ] sorry I just got
worked up anyways let's come let's
finish this the game comes from an old
english game of rounders which was by
and large a game of women the [ __ ] is he
talking about now
you know I don't even give a [ __ ]
anymore
whilst me we me were while the real me
were playing rugby and football
what now Jesus Christ you trying to say
baseball was made up by a woman that's
how he trying to say you know what I
love everybody acts like they [ __ ]
hate America and they can't stop paying
attention to us
I don't listen any English douchebags
podcast you know I don't know a [ __ ]
thing all I know tony blair tony blair
bitched up and [ __ ] sent you guys you
know got you guys into [ __ ] iraq too
cuz you have any balls you know why cuz
he plays soccer wow that was really
[ __ ] me alright
underrated check out this Scottish
comedian Frankie Boyle very dark but
funny Scottish guys are [ __ ]
hilarious I look forward to your non
reap non reply and if I do get past your
filtering process [ __ ] up reading
this out loud well I did all of that I
don't have any filtering process I read
all of these goddamn things I have
nothing better to do where are we in
this podcast forty-four [ __ ] minutes
alright let's get to some overrated and
underrated well [ __ ] we go alright
overrated okay overrated drummer Neil
Peart now before all the prog rock tech
heads start quoting Modern Drummer hear
me out
we've had the technology since the 1960s
to program a computer to play
polyrhythmic beats
try having GarageBand play Elvin Jones
or rashid ali i don't know who that is
dude you can't say that man those are
different kinds of drummers although I'm
not really into Neil Peart I'm not into
him I think he's I don't know he's just
too [ __ ] on the beat he sounds like a
robot
he's [ __ ] amazing but uh I like I
don't know I think people either like
John Bonham or you like Neil Peart you
know what I mean nobody gives a [ __ ]
they're not drummers alright I think
that's it I think that's gonna be it for
the podcast
as I'm [ __ ] trying to get a gig in
England I just [ __ ] trash to
everybody over there I'm just you know
everybody just [ __ ] trash an American
on [ __ ] stop now and then you go to
their countries and you know you see fat
[ __ ] you see losers I don't know what
they're bragging above I really don't
they talk about how amazing their beer
is I got a mitt I went to Sweden they
did have some good beers man a couple
beers from actually had one from
Czechoslovakia some checks some [ __ ]
that doesn't even exist anymore the
Czech Republic whatever the [ __ ] it is I
don't know that's another thing that
bugs me about Europeans they think
they're so [ __ ] worldly because they
know all about Europe and [ __ ] and it's
like Europe is like basically the size
of half of America so if you know
something about this state next to you
that's the same as like somebody from
England knowing about France I mean you
can [ __ ] drive there at this point
it's really none impressive but it is
beautiful over there whatever Hitler
didn't bomb bomb and his still left
standing is very nice all right I was a
little Kunti this week just cuz I was
tired I'll blame it on that
and I think that's it I think that's all
that I have to say this week I just want
to thank everybody for the tremendous
turnout the tremendous turnout in
Philadelphia I actually had to stay in X
today and add a show that was awesome
let me height my shows coming up and
don't you English [ __ ] kid all pissed
off of what the [ __ ] I say because I
don't even read half the [ __ ] that you
guys write you know calling me up
telling me if I talk about American
sports it's boring as if I give a fly-in
[ __ ] you know alright let me get to my
website obviously I give a [ __ ] I'm
bringing it up and I also if you if
you're just trying to write [ __ ] to piss
me off it's gonna work because I have to
respond to everything because I have
that disease where I have to make my
point all right let's get to the what I
got coming up not this weekend next
weekend I'm gonna be the Improv in
Addison Texas September 24th 25th 26th
and also the Sunday is that the 27th I
think I added the day because I'm
hanging around going to that Cowboys
game
let me see here checking out the
calendar yeah and the 27th I'll be there
Thursday through Sunday we added a
Sunday show I'm gonna be there goddammit
so bring your friends down and I'll see
it the Cowboys game on Monday then on
October 2nd 3rd and 4th I'm gonna be at
the stress factory in New Brunswick New
Jersey and the following weekend I'll be
at the improv in Pittsburgh and all the
rest of my dates are up my website I
want to thank everybody for all the
great support I've really had a
tremendous last couple of gigs here you
know going to Atlanta over to Stockholm
Sweden and then down to Philadelphia
really tremendous turnout I really
appreciate it and all you guys basically
out there asking me when I'm gonna come
to your country you know Australia New
Zealand I'm working on that [ __ ] I'm
gonna uh try to put some YouTube videos
up on I discovered when I was in
Stockholm Sweden that YouTube you know
there's like literally just like
Wikipedia you know what I mean there's
all kinds of different youtubes I just
stuck with the English one because I'm a
[ __ ] American surrounded by people
speaking English and water but I'm gonna
try to get some [ __ ] up on maybe the
Australian one the England English one
or whatever I guess evidently that's a
way to build a following over there so
hopefully I can travel over there and
maybe I'll check out some of your
sporting events and maybe I'll change my
opinions but you know something I would
be way more open to enjoying sports from
England or someplace else if you could
just tell me about him without [ __ ]
trash and you know American sports first
if you just want to hear me flip out
then by all means continue what you're
doing cuz it's working all right
but you know hey no disrespect to your
troops that went over to Iraq too you
know I just wanna make sure I didn't get
a little out of hand there all right
this is all jokes so don't send me any
[ __ ] hate mail alright that's the
money mony podcast for this week thank
you everybody for listening and I know
there was one other [ __ ] thing I
didn't get to maybe I'll get to it next
week that's it that's it for the podcast
everybody have a great week
[Music]
[Applause]